thank you welcome I scouted this place
last week to see what's going on here so
still have an audience that's good so
this is not about football I'm sorry to
tell you it's it's about ideas and it's
about my life and it's about your life
so as Tina says I actually started as a
pretty straight mechanical engineer out
of New York City I still have the accent
and only been off the boat 50 some-odd
years so takes a while and I have three
degrees in mechanical engineering that I
actually earned and after my PhD I
actually was supposed to stay at
Columbia but I got a free vacation to
California and since my wife hated New
York we ended up staying at Stanford and
I've been here since 1962 which is
before a lot of you have been born and
so I've been here a long time and the
thing to understand is the Stanford and
the Silicon Valley I came to is very
very different or was very different
than it is today and one of the things
that struck me when I was here is a
there was the human potential movement
and all that so I learned there were
other things that machines and robots
there were people and I got interested
in that and creativity but and I started
to think about teaching in addition to
the things I knew something about the
things I wish I had to learn to school
myself and one of the things I noticed
was that people talked a lot about
starting their own companies and most of
them didn't in the design program where
I was in Emmie most of students ended up
working for youlet packard will may be
Ampex which doesn't exist anymore rake
hem which doesn't exist
but they went to these large companies
and they all had this kind of pipe dream
this fantasy of starting their own
company and that kind of I didn't really
care but it actually reminded me of a
play called The Iceman Cometh an O'Neill
play and in that play these people are
in the bar and the whole play takes
place in the
bar and they talk about leaving the bar
and the whole play nobody leaves the bar
and somehow this whole idea of starting
a company reminded me of that it
bothered me a lot so I decided to start
a course which had in a - you could do a
project and the project involved one of
two topics one was do something you've
never done before in your life when the
other was get rid of a problem in your
life and then we had all sorts of
processes some of the things I wrote
about in the book are from that class
and it kind of was really interesting
because what I hit upon was this whole
idea that if you do something you're
never the same
it's kind of really interesting and so
people did projects which you know they
weren't kind of academic projects they
were jumping out of airplanes and riding
motorcycles and the building stuff and
all that and I noticed the people it
changed people it gave him a kind of
impetus and this whole idea of doing
became a very important part of my life
and my teaching and it's rather than
talk about it let's do it and the whole
pragmatic thing is if it works in your
life fine it'll incorporate it and
change you if you want to if it doesn't
work forget about it and do something
else
so I kind of developed this class which
is called designers society based on
these principles and my life was pretty
okay and I developed something called
the creativity workshop which we get
around the world and from professors and
that was kind of great and then about 12
years ago or so this thing called the
d.school appeared in my life and it was
sort of a sidelight for me
and then david kelly who was sort of the
principal of the people who found that
it got cancer and i was at home minding
my own business Friday night at about 11
o'clock at night and I got a call from
Jim Plummer who was the Dean of
engineering those days and he said I'm
really uncomfortable with David being
out for his treatments not having a
faculty person in charge there and would
you do that till he comes back so I said
sure I didn't negotiate or any other
such fine and then
Monday morning I walked into the
d.school and I never left and it totally
changed my life
and what it did is it kind of took the
things we have been talking about always
we in those days we call the need
finding and we changed it to human
centered design and it kind of was a way
to express all these things which were
kind of they were kind of part of my
life but really there was a too many
other pieces to make it all come
together and when I got to the d.school
it kind of crystallized this thing we
call design thinking is really what
we've been talking about all along and
we really can use it for the things
rather than designing stuff so let me
just make that clear
this business thing called design
thinking the world which you've probably
heard about and the way the name came
about its uses methods that
traditionally were used by designers the
design stuff uses some of those ideas
and but now it applies it to almost
everything so it's it's very widespread
in business now it's in health I cannot
tell you how many different groups want
me to talk about design thinking nurses
and trainers and all this kind of you
know you name it a groups of people
working with one source um I use design
thinking in the world and people come
into the d.school and think we can cure
a cancer and all that so it's kind of
you know it kind of gets a little
inflated but really it's a kind of good
useful tool in problem-solving and all
that and what I decided to do is to
apply it to ourselves
and I thought my colleagues would kill
me because one of the things in design
thinking is don't design for yourself
design for someone else okay and that's
a really good thing because others can
see things you can't see but to me it
doesn't mean you can also use it until
something better comes along use it on
yourself and so I try to use the
principles of design thinking and my
ideas and creativity and my teaching
from the designer society to make a kind
of holistic thing for you and me to go
forward in the world and these are
things I've used with students for you
know 40 some odd years so I know they
work and I've use them in my life so I
know that they work also
what I want to do today is share some of
these things with you and the first
thing is this whole idea of problem
solving so first of all problems have a
bad rap not around here because Tina's
brainwashed everyone that there are
opportunities but basically in the real
world problems have a bad rap because
people think oh it's a problem it's oh
it's terrible and all that stuff but in
fact it's important to understand that
that's that's where my life force comes
from and I'm sure there are others in
the room whose life force comes for that
also so when I have a problem I'm
excited I can't sleep I get up I'm
always activated to do that and in fact
that's kind of what it's about and one
of my favorite stories is a book that
was written in the 1800's in the Russian
Imperial Russia about a character called
Oblomov and for the first 250 pages of
the book he doesn't get out of bed and
the whole light it's a fantasy but the
whole idea was to be critical this
aristocracy that has no reason to get
out of bed and everything is taken care
of for them why would you get out of bed
if everything is taken care of for you
so that's the kind of idea to understand
about problems it's a good reason to get
out of bed okay and if people get
depressed they don't get out of bed you
know so it's a good song you want to get
out of bed so you get out of bed and
that's great you got these things which
are energizing and you want to work on
them and we have them in our lives and
most of people in this room are great
problem solvers and I think of myself as
a great problem solver so the question
is why do people like you and me have
things in our lives which are troubling
which we cannot handle how come we're so
smart you're a very smart guy I can tell
right off the bat you're a smart guy too
and you're a smart woman right sure we
all know that I must say this is an
aside but I went to Memorial memorial
service for Sandy Dawn Bush who was a
colleague I knew for many years from
sociology and I heard he would tell his
students don't worry that you don't feel
smart when you go home for Christmas
break you'll feel smart again
so the point this point was everyone is
so smart around here that's how I like
to feel smart okay so whether that's
true or not it's a it's a nice nice
thought so we're here now and the
question is you okay you most of you
address properly you found this room you
kind of got into Stanford you know you
have a lot of accomplishments so why is
it you and I lose sleep about something
okay and I have a theory what that is
and I say that most of the time it's
because we're trying to solve the wrong
problem so my statement to you is if you
have a problem that you are really
losing sleep over and that you cannot
solve it's because you're working on the
wrong problem it's as simple as that and
I have seen that in my PhD reads you
know I used to be an expert on robotics
and kinematics and stuff like that and I
would have PhD students come in and I
knew the field very well I've been
researching for many years and I give
them a problem and would work for a
couple years and then suddenly would
realize oh it wasn't really the real
question is this
it wasn't a big change but we realized
suddenly what the gem was and we did
that the student could finish up in a
couple of months right up and go on with
their lives and it was a really great
example where here we had a lot of
expertise and yet we didn't know what
the real question was and I've seen that
when companies come in and they were
consulting things they ask you to do
something and it's the wrong question
and it appears over and over again and
it certainly appears in my everyday life
so what I want you to understand is it's
really easy it's what we call in Design
Thinking reframing the problem and the
secret is to reframe it and the question
is how do I do that and the answer is
really really simple and the way I
suggest you do it if you ask yourself
what it would do for you if you solve
the problem
ask yourself what it would do for you if
you solve the problem
and that is the question you want to ask
yourself so I'll give you an example
where I totally failed so I rented a car
and I drove up to the wine country and
the venchik Iran out of gas and I pulled
into the gas station and I started to
look for the release for the cover to
the gas tank and I must have looked for
10 minutes in the glove compartment
every every place normal and designers
would put it and I couldn't find it I
was kind of frustrated and then I
noticed a similar car drove up for
guests so I went up to the lady and I
said I noticed this stupid question but
where is the release she said there is
none okay and so at that point I
realized what I was doing I I had my I
had framed the question to where the
releases and why would I will if I
played my game which I did of course but
if I played my game I would say what
would I do for me if I could find the
release well I'd be able to get the
cover open so now the question is how do
I get the cover open okay and if you get
the cover open the easiest ways walk
over and open it up okay so it's a silly
secend silly trivial question but it in
fact embodies the whole idea okay so
what I'd like you to do is not take my
word for it that it works and I can
assure you it's worked for thousands of
people around the world and it will work
for you so I would like you to play that
game right now in your own head I'd like
you to and I don't take something like
peace in the world forever you know
that's not gonna work all right but take
something literally that you lose sleep
over like you know should you go on the
date with so-and-so or should you do
this or should you go for graduate work
or she have something normal and coming
or should you tell you roommate she's
making too much noise at night anything
that bothers you really and that we're
currently you haven't been able to solve
even though you're so smart so take that
problem and ask yourself what it would
do for you if you solve that just I'm
going to be quiet for a few minutes and
ask yourself what do we do if we solve
that and like in my case I would
the gas tank cover opens and I change it
to how do I get the gas tank cover open
so in your case you can ask what it
would do for you and you're going to
change it to a problem okay so go ahead
and do that and I'll drink some water
okay enough of you look alert so I'm
gonna assume most of you got in there so
does anyone have any troubles doing that
exercise now it's going to figure out
what the new question is so did you have
you figure out what the new question is
not sure you want to want me to interact
with you and enlighten you and save your
life okay good someone have something
yeah okay so okay great so so your
problem what would happen what would
happen to you if you get to promise how
to get out of bed right not waking up
you wake up you're awake okay I'm trying
to figure out myself but he said he has
a problem when waking up in the morning
getting out of bed and I'm trying to
figure out if the waking up is the
problem with the getting out of bed is
the problem the waking up is fine but
game bats the question is once he's
woken how does he get out of bed okay so
the question you have to ask yourself is
what would it do for you if you could
get out of bed in the morning okay so
now the question is how how do I get out
of bed in the morning okay
so give me some ideas we can I can get
brainstorm can you think of any ways of
getting out of bed in the morning
okay that's one way okay what else well
what would it do I do you want to get
out of bed in the morning that's what
would it do for you if you got out of
bed in the morning
see you're not letting go in the
original question that's the issue so
what would do for you so let's say get
more work done so the question is how do
you get more work done it has nothing to
do with getting out of bed if you're
real if that's really you know we're
just playing a game here but this is the
insight so pay attention this is you
sitting here okay it's a gift to you
he thinks it's getting out of bed it's
not getting out of bed it's getting more
work done if that's true so are there
ways to get more work done I could
figure out and stay in bed and get more
work done as an example okay and there
are lots of ways of getting well I don't
know what your life is like but probably
you could think of a hundred ways to get
more work done and if you can't the
people in this room who know how to do
it they'll tell you so if you really was
that was the problem you got you've
opened up your solution space so we've
opened up the solution space where we no
longer hung up on getting out of bed now
it sounds trivial knows how to get a bed
and he does too so it's not a great
example and it is a great example you
understand what I'm saying it's a great
example because the structure is exactly
what you're doing with your problem it's
exactly what you're doing with your
problem and if silliest pardon me as
silly as this sounds yours is a silly
also okay it's a Sibley's I know let's
try some other victim here who else and
I'm going to give you a reward I'm not
I'm not the kind of guy who takes
advantage of people without you this
will have more meaning to you later on
okay and I'm gonna give you a reward
even though you didn't participate so I
give her Ward's hijos the psychological
training you understand yes what's yours
I have to translate all this so make it
very succinctly
the problem you don't know how to go
about changing social behavior that's
her problem what would it do for you if
you knew how to go about South changing
social behavior so I want to know how to
generate more donations can you generate
more donations without changing social
behavior see that's the whole thing is
there any way to generate more donations
without changing social behavior yes
there are there are lots of ways okay I
have a way you take out a gun and you
ask people for money it's one way right
that's the way generate more money okay
another way is scamming and swindling
and anyone else anyone know you in bed
you must be thinking of some way to
change
it's got no seriously see that's the
point you know she's locked into one
thing and won't let go of that one thing
if that's really a problem and if you've
been trying it for four months you gotta
let go you know I read somewhere that we
have between 50,000 60,000 thoughts a
day I don't know if that's true but we
do think a lot
however the tricky thing is that 95% of
those are repeated thoughts and 80% of
those are things that are fear and can't
do kind of thoughts so just sitting and
thinking for three months you're not
going to get another thought about
social behavior I guarantee you so you
have to reframe the problem and the way
to reef it's like oh so you're not
listening to me you don't want to do it
what I'm telling you that's where it is
and it's really hard to let go of
problems it really is really interesting
people just won't let go their problem
so if you tell them say well what if the
cause is all that just let go of it
forget about it it's not working for you
no you don't see you saying it but you
know I don't believe you can do it are
you gonna do it I'm gonna reward you but
I don't believe you okay let's take one
more then we'll move on anyone anyone
else so if you're not raising your hand
oh you have good yes okay okay what
would it do foot so she's with a startup
and she's having trouble getting
appliance a client's to pay the full fee
so the question is what would it do for
you if you got your clients to pay the
full fee
okay you have a good professional
relationships of course if you don't if
you don't get them to pay the feed I'll
have a better relationship with you
right you know so the question is how do
you get a better relationship if that's
what it is but you of course want the
money right so so the relationship is
the kind of that Harry
it's a red herring so a question is how
can I get my clients to pay the money
which is the original question what
would it do for you if you got your
clients to pay the money all the money
what are you gonna do with all that
money when you get it here
you're gonna invest it okay you can
invest in your project so you need to
find money to invest in your project is
there any way to is there anyone in this
room who has ever found any money to
invest in their project which they
didn't get from a client paying them
there's anyone any of the figured out
how to get any money in Silicon Valley
to invest in the project other than
getting your client to pay for you you
see do you see what I'm saying
she stuck with that thing and she'll be
banging your head against the client not
paying her I hope they pay her but if
they don't pay you so what if you really
want to do what you said which is to get
money for something else if that doesn't
work get money somewhere else you're not
gonna let go either another one these
people won't let go so it see if you
don't let him go it's you really don't
want to solve the problem it's as simple
as that
you want to make your clients wrong for
not paying I agree to a bunch of
son-of-a-bitches that they don't pay but
that's the point yep if that's really
now I know we're playing a game here I'm
gonna give her a reward anyway I'm not
that tough but this point simply is I
think you can see in these examples that
in fact it is simply that if you really
stuck if this is real I mean this is
just a game we're playing but if this is
really a problem you're stuck with you
have to be willing to say what would it
really do for me if I got that not how
will I do it
see we're stuck in that we're
implementing a solution we're not really
looking at the question
her case the question is how do I get
money to do other things it would be
great if she got it from a client but
she's not so what no it's so what
there's other ways of getting money if
that's what the question is rather than
bumping herself and not doing it I hope
she gets it from your client but if you
don't you don't want to spend your life
worrying about that you want to go on
and do the other thing and this is the
way you do it say what do I really want
and the solution space opens up
tremendously you could also use the gun
and the robbery that I suggested for her
work slow ok good any questions about
the process yeah it's whenever you want
to there's no such thing as have to give
up there's no such thing as have to do
it it's up to you you know all I'm
saying is if you start and you're losing
sleep the chances are it's the wrong
question or else she would have found it
she says she's working on it for 3
months if she's been really working on
it for 3 months she's not gonna find
there she works on it for another 3
months she has to find the real question
and then the is will be obvious it will
be obvious it's a simple I've been
through it a lot of times I'll give you
my book ask some examples how I really
screwed up so I learned the hard way ok
ok so that's the first thing if you're
gonna solve problems you really want to
be working on the right problem ok and
then putting my good example yeah yes
that's too hypothetical for me ok let me
show you what what it's about this is my
favorite story in this issue there's a
drunk walking along and he hits a
lamppost and he bounces off and he hits
a lamppost and he bounces off and we can
give the lamppost various names but hits
a lamppost and he bounces off he goes
back we don't that much like he hits a
lamppost and he goes I give up they got
me surrounded
and that's the way you are that's
exactly the way you are but you're not
drunk if you're not willing to let go
you're gonna keep banging against it
you're gonna keep banging against it and
then you're gonna surrender because they
have you surrounded and if you're not
drunk you go Oh an obstacle an obstacle
an obstacle and obstacle oh that's it I
got it I'm through you understand the
whole idea is everyone's gonna have
obstacles in their lives if it's a tough
car well she solved it you dress
properly you've got to stand for you got
a front row seat here you you solved a
lot of problems you just got this one
little thing your clients are not paying
you so what you're gonna make your whole
life your clients aren't paying you or
you're gonna go ahead and do what you
want to do she's psyching but still not
good anyway let me shut my phone off
quick before you get embarrassed okay so
so you don't want to be like the drunk
even though you're sober but most of us
act that way really it's just a matter
of walking around the obstacle okay so
what wonder ways that kind of get us
entrapped assuming you have the right
problem it often solves itself however
things happen things come up one of the
first things that come up is it doesn't
kind of work like he throws his clock
across the room but somehow he doesn't
get up and get it so if I asked him why
he doesn't go up and get it he'll give
me a reason
he's a very reasonable guy could tell
he's a reasonable guy he'll give me a
reason why he doesn't get up to go to
clock if I ask her something she'll give
me a reason why she can't change social
behavior if I ask her something she'll
give me a reason why she can't collect
from her clients okay and they're all
reasons okay except in my world and I
hate to use this bad word here always
the [ __ ] all reasons for human but
personal behavior are just [ __ ] and
I mean it in the sense of you don't know
where it is you making it up so I use
[ __ ] in the sense of you're making
up something which is you don't know if
it's true or not and it goes like this
if I ask you for the reason you did some
if you ask me why I'm here I'll tell you
Tina invited me that is nothing there's
no lie in that but it's [ __ ] because
Tina could have invited me and I could
have not come and I could have probably
if I really wanted to get here maybe
gotten through this Tina and got someone
else to invite me so the point simply is
there's a million reasons I got here one
of which is Tina invited me and if you
ask me that's the most reasonable thing
to tell you so I want to be a reasonable
guy I'll tell you and you'll go about
your business and that's fine who cares
the problem is that often we hide
excuses as reasons and we'll never
change our behavior if we don't tell
ourselves the truth so and I'll
elaborate on that in a minute
so the point simply is there's a lot of
things that go on Tina and I have a very
complicated relationship starting from
when we first met where we hated each
other and all of that and now she's the
most supportive friend I have in terms
of my book and stuff like that so
there's like a lot of things going on
between me and Tina and between anyone
any friends you know I mean nothing
secret going on here after one came out
the wrong way Mike I didn't mean it Mike
it came out the wrong way but you know
we have a complicated relationship as we
do with all our friends okay so the fact
that you choose to give you a reason you
just single you something out my
favorite is right now my mouth is
terribly dry so if you ask me why my
mouth is dry I'll say I'm talking a lot
and that seems obvious however every
time I talk my mouth is dry however my
wife is always telling me drink more
water I'm chronically dehydrated when I
go to Burning Man I don't pee the right
colors you know I'm not that my whole
life is one of dehydration every time I
talk I know this is going to come up I
also of course drank a bottle of the
wine last night etc etc etc so there's a
lot of things that could have caused my
dehydrated dry mouth so the one I tell
you is I'm talking a lot it's obvious
it's a weight that's the way you have to
be in life but I will never change my
behavior
if I don't if I don't tell myself that I
really don't know the reason okay now
let me explain where my epiphany comes
from my epiphany comes from a board
meeting in Berkeley I was on a startup
company I was on the board of directors
and we'd have regular meetings and the
company didn't fail but quite well so I
had to keep going to meetings and I was
always late I was always late always and
I'd come in and those days it was
highway 17 and I come in I say oh the
traffic on highway 17 was terrible and
they'd all say it's okay Bertie was just
glad nothing happened and all that and
it's okay and I knew it wasn't okay
these are people who have lives and all
that and I was just holding them back
and it was just and of course I realized
what it was is I wasn't leaving enough
time and I wasn't leaving enough time
since I didn't give them and a valence
in my life it wasn't important enough to
me so I realized I were to make a
decision I rather resigned from the
board or I ought to be there on time and
getting our time was as easy as getting
out of bed and it was just simply not
doing in those days we had a teletype of
my office which to do email not doing a
few extra emails not making focal no
cell phones in those days believe it or
not not making a few extra cell phone
calls and not talking to a colleague in
the hall as I was leaving the building
and leaving enough time so even if there
was imagine that traffic in Palo Alto
and traffic in Berkeley in traffic on
highway 17 I get there on time once I
got that epiphany it changed my whole
life I used to be the person who was
always late to everything
now I'm the pain-in-the-ass who starts
everything on time I'm always on time
my former chairman he was terrified
about me because he was always late
Bernie's coming I got to be on top and
people read the book they're afraid to
come in two minutes late so it's not
that really bit but it's a great example
of reasons so the being late was
[ __ ] there was traffic on highway 17
but that was not the reason I was late
there were a million other reasons I was
like okay so the point simply is who
cares
you care if you want to change your
behavior
just like my epiphany about it wasn't
the traffic on highway 17 that was
making my late change my behavior about
time
it can change your behavior about a lot
of things if you care and the way you
have to do it is not is not to tell
yourself a lie and the way you have a
lie is you tell yourself a reason
because you're so complex you and I are
such complex being that there is no one
single reason for anything I always like
to tell people of some progenitor three
generations ago hadn't had sex you
wouldn't have been here so that's why my
mouth's dry you know it's nonsense
rights that's stupid isn't it so the
whole idea is simply you're picking out
the one that makes sense
but it's a million reasons it's not a
reason for anything and the other
interesting thing is that people don't
experiments they've put people in MRI
machines and they've had them push a
button or something and they look at the
parts of the brain that fires and then
they ask them what they did and it turns
out the part of the brain that works on
the actual mechanical muscular control
fires before the part of the brain the
cortex that works on the reasons so what
happens in most cases is you do what you
do and then you make up a reason for it
and that's what a reasonable person is a
reasonable person can explain their
behavior and they're reasonable so you
want to be a reasonable person however
you want to not fool yourself so what I
do if you asked me why I came here or
why my mouth is dry I'll tell you I'm
talking a lot of a teen advice and I
know that's [ __ ] now it doesn't
matter in this case however in some
cases like coming late to the board
meeting like other things it does matter
and I will never change my behavior as
long as I tell myself that lie so what I
do if you ask me a question I'm
reasonable I give you a reasonable
answer and I go now I'm never going to
say that again
and of course I say it again but
eventually I change okay so the point
simply is if you get to view that all
social reasons for your behavior are
really you don't know what they are and
you're just making it up you
be much more powerful if your behaviors
not what you want you can change it and
don't use the reason because that's just
an excuse and we all know excuses are
pejorative things so if I ask him he
doesn't go out of bed he'll give me a
minute excuses why he can't get a bed
but if he actually wants to get out of
bed you stop scaring yourself the
[ __ ] reasons he could get out of bed
okay and get less done well more done I
figure what you want to do okay but
handy but any rage okay so and it works
so well I get it in funny it just
happened this morning again I get maybe
four emails a week from some students
somewhere in the world who wants to come
to Stanford and do a PhD with me I can
ignore those emails I don't have any
connection to most of these people it's
not that someone they just picking me
randomly and they're probably going
every professor in the world I somehow
feel it's nice to respond they've put a
lot of work into it they give me their
resume their life story so I used to say
I'm sorry I can't take you because I
don't have any money or I'm going on
sabbatical or something nice to let him
down easy
and what would invariably happen is I
get pushback oh well you don't have any
money I have a rich uncle he'll support
me are you going on sabbatical how about
I come a year from now whatever I'd say
they'd have some go and the email would
go on in sometimes I just truncate out
of first station now that I'm
enlightened
I say sorry can help you good luck you
know what happens half the time I get
back one message thank you very much for
answering my email professor I feel good
about that I feel much better than not
answering and it's over and they
apparently feel good about it I don't
know maybe they're building me up they
think they're gonna come back next yeah
I don't know but it just seems like so
much but I just say what I can do what I
can't do without giving the reasons so
what I'm advocating is live your life as
Reason free as you possibly can
it really helps it really helps now they
have a lot of people in my little domain
of the d.school and in this design group
of Stanford have taken my workshops so
when some poor professor in my design
group who likes to complain
a lot gets up and he says at the meeting
well the reason I can't do this is the
Dean said blah blah blah he's greeted by
a chorus that's a good reason okay
meaning it's [ __ ] okay so so it's a
little embarrassing but in fact he gets
the benefit of knowing that it's just
the Dean is not stopping him the Dean is
not the deans doing whatever the deans
is doing and he could do whatever he
does so I want you to understand when I
say good reason I spelled with five O's
so I mean good reason there's not a good
reason at all you got the idea okay so
what I want to do is give you that
experience right because you didn't want
to take my word for it some of you look
like what's this guy talking about no or
less so what I want you to do is as
close as you can get a part in the next
to you and if you can't go to the next
row I'll give you a two minutes to get a
partner so everyone just get a partner
you could work with hopefully someone
sitting next to you but and if you don't
have a partner raise your hand we'll get
you part
so wait you and I are going to
demonstrate tighten the raise your hand
anyway might have a point all right
anyone willing to admit they don't have
a point okay good
so the ideas that Tina and I are going
to demonstrate the game to you so I'm
going to say to Tina the reason why I'm
my mouth is rise I'm talking so much
that's a good reason the reason I'm here
because you invited me that's a good
reason the reason I'm talking about this
is a way to advertise my book okay see
these are all things in my life that are
all true okay and she's done now she's
going to tell me at some point and I'm
just gonna keep going so one of you is
going to keep going at some point I'm
gonna say change roles at that point
she's going to give me something that's
in her life and I'm gonna say that's a
good reason and every time she tells me
something gonna acknowledge that's a
good reason okay and just don't judge it
just see how that feels to you and
really trying this prove Bernie you know
in May 8th one counterexample disproves
everything give something that's really
a good thing that is a real reason and
when you get back that's a good reason
and think about it for a minute okay so
that's the everyone got the experiment
there's a real-life experiment so please
start one partner starts giving things
and their partner says it's a good
reason then I'll tell you when to switch
roles go ahead
okay thank you thank you okay anyone
have any comments or questions or good
reasons anything anyone so let me just
explain it to you another way if a
student comes into my class and she says
I'm sorry professor I had a flat tire on
my bike I'm sorry for being late
that sounds great and even if she had
the flat tire if the rule was if you
come into a class you failed the class
she would not have been late even if she
had a flat tire
it's as simple as that if the rule is if
you're late to a class you get kicked
out of Stanford everything would start
on time at Stanford it's just a matter
of caring it's a matter of putting
enough valence in it I gave a talk at
Google this was a riot this was like it
couldn't be tailor-made there was one
person didn't have a partner so I ended
up working with her so she says and she
came in late says she says the reason I
was late is I work in the other building
I loved it it was like I could have
kissed her right the reason she's late
as she works in the other building and
she thought that was real
I was at a PhD exam in the ed school and
we're waiting a half hour for a
professor from Berkeley and they were
all sitting there saying oh she's coming
from Berkeley
so she comes a half-hour late where
she's coming from
so it's the whole world doesn't care
about that stuff if you don't care it's
fine if you don't care it's fine but you
have to understand that if you want to
change your behavior you cannot use
these excuses which you call reasons and
you have to just give things more
valence to your life it's as simple as
that
okay and I won't even tell you about the
collection mafia she's gonna hire to get
the money but you have to just give it a
little more of alias there are ways okay
okay good so that's so so far we have
covered getting the right problem to
work on and we have covered the idea
that reasons of [ __ ] in my world and
I hope you'll make them in your world
and yes sir I forget thank you thank you
I'm gonna give you a present I'm gonna
give you to person because this is
something you do not want to try at home
believe me I have never been doing it
for a long time I have never once told
my wife her reasons of [ __ ] I have
never once told my son's the reasons of
[ __ ] I have never once told my
buddies my biking buddies every and I've
never once told my colleagues in the
d.school
or in the design group that the reasons
are [ __ ] I just tell Bernie Roth if
I fix myself the world is better you
cannot do it I mean if you're taking my
workshop so I can tell you giving me
license people are not signing up for
your workshop your friends your
roommates your family is not signed up
for your workshop it's believing I've
been in this business a long time I used
to do black wax workshops I've done
s-somewhere I've got a lot of workshop
you do not want to do this stuff if
you're not the Guru fix yourself you can
be the Guru for yourself do not be the
Guru for someone else just showing by
example you will ruin your relationship
so seriously speaking do not thank you
that's a great gift because I met I mean
to say it and sometimes I forget it and
then at night I feel horrible what I've
created in the world a bunch of my bunch
of monsters you know a bunch of monsters
do not do that it's it really takes
something wonderful and nice and turns
it to something awful okay thank you
okay okay so I want this one other thing
I want to do and that came up with your
question there and there's a difference
between trying and doing and the thing
about it is there's this wonderful line
in the Star Wars movie the first one
with Yoda and I'm always afraid when I
says that I'm gonna be struck down dead
but self I've gotten away with it
Yoda was wrong and not in the context
that he was doing okay but the point is
there is a troy he said there's no try
to just do okay and people love to quote
that especially entrepreneurs that but
the point simply is there are there's a
trying is to do and they're both okay
states there's really nothing wrong with
trying to do something and there's
certainly nothing wrong with doing it
the problem is when you think they're
the same thing and when you think you're
doing something you're really just
trying and when you're trying when you
hit an obstacle the lamppost you get
defeated and when you're doing it
doesn't matter if there's a lamppost you
jump over it you knock it down or you
walk around it so they're your obstacles
I had a fellow who's sort of dear in my
life in that he's a great story he was a
Stanford student kind of days when I got
here way back when and he was a swimmer
and he had a bad accent in the shower
and he had to have the back surgery and
the doctors told him he'd never swim
again and he wanted to go to the
Olympics so he ignored the doctor's
advice he got some guy to take him down
to Saratoga reservoir trained the hell
out of him he just qualified just barely
qualified he went to Rome and he won a
gold medal and he came back and he put
the gold medal on the doctors desk and
he set the world record also at the time
okay so that and he told me he was just
down here to become a lifelong friend
and he's a serial serial entrepreneur
he's the most entrepreneurial guy I've
ever met
okay and he did pemmican beef jerky
maybe a product you know without no
which was a really good product uh and
he told me no Bernie every time I have
hit a block that's what got me to do
something really great and creative he
said everything in my life it was like
the swimming thing I probably would have
never gotten there if I hadn't gone
through that surgery in that whole
accident and even there's another story
about how he got the event law and he
has like 20 things he's done and they're
really very good things they were and he
said every time there's been something
I've just had it go bad that's what made
me creative let me see that
so the whole idea is to if you're doing
something you're going to do it no
matter what and just having a block can
be a gift having a block can be a big
gift because it gets you to see
something that you wouldn't have seen
okay and but even if it isn't a gift you
still have to go around it so the whole
idea is not to do trying and doing I'll
tell you one story I could tell you this
because my wife isn't here and she won't
watch it on the tube and she hates when
I tell the story however to me it's the
one story which really says it all and
the story is the following we were up in
San Francisco visiting my son and we was
about to drive home and we passed the
Roxy theater which is in the Mission
District and it's a kind of funky
theater and it shows things you'd never
see elsewhere and the line was bigger
than I've ever seen in front of the Roxy
and I noticed it had a band it was a
movie about a band and the band was
there I never heard of them but I think
this is hot we got to go so I said let's
go you know though I'm tired let's go
home I said come on let's say okay we'll
go I said jump out you buy the tickets
and I'll go park the car so I come back
ten minutes later and she's not online
and I say well why aren't you online she
said I couldn't get tested why not why
couldn't get ting she said they sold out
but why couldn't you get things just
sold out didn't you hear me stay here
for a few minutes so I went out and I
got two tickets so the point was and she
was right it was terrible we shouldn't
the guy
but the point the point simply was she
was trying
she was accommodating me and she hit an
obstacle they were sold out which was
true and that was it she was defeated
and it was it was okay she didn't mind
she didn't mind she tried and that's the
whole idea of trying if it works fun she
would have gone if she would have bought
two tickets she would have gone and but
she couldn't fish in the trying is that
way if it works fine if it doesn't work
the doing is different doing is if they
sold out it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter if they sold out you're gonna get
two tickets okay and it succeeded
example now I have trying in my life I'm
not a jerk like some people they only do
if I have to kill him I will change my
mind
I will not don't worry I'm going to
change me I'm going to change my mind
from doing to try okay but the whole
idea is I had an episode I was supposed
to go to a meeting in Texas and I really
was reluctant to go and it was my
obligation because they'd given me some
money so I went to the airport and I met
my good friend Krista Donaldson there we
both were there and the gods were good
Dallas Forth Worth was closed because of
snow storms so I called up and said
really sorry I can't come it's just snow
storm they said that's okay and we both
went to a home so we were the happiest
could be so that was great but if I
really was going to go onto to get there
do you think having a snow storm in
Dallas forth where it would have stopped
me from getting to Dallas Forth Worth if
my life depended on getting to Dallas
Forth Worth I would have gotten there so
trying is great at times I'm not
knocking it that's what Yoda was wrong
but you have to be appropriate and you
have to know when to stop trying if
you're not doing it and start doing well
forget about the whole thing and do
something else okay so I have to leave a
little time for questions I must leave
four minutes for questions that's more
than enough we've been doing so many
good so thank you let's have questions
yes how to teach the habit because
absolutely it's a great question how do
you change the habit it's really hard to
do it one at a time it's it's it's it's
a woman did a story in The New York
Times about this soldier stance and she
called me up and she said we want to do
a project for New Year's and what should
we do and I said well the way we do in
the D schools we give the readers
something to do and she said well give
me an example so I said well what's give
me something in your life that's really
hard to do what she said well to tell
you the truth I've gained a lot of
weight I'm embarrassed to go out and see
my friends and all of that and I said
well what would it do for you what would
it do for you if you if you if you lost
the weight I'd be able to have a social
life so I said well the problem I would
give you is a readers go have a social
life nothing happens sometime later the
article comes out I lost 25 pounds doing
this is the thinking stuff so I wrote
her a note and I said thank you very
much she says I'm a believer okay so in
her case she changed the habit by
reframing the problem however the way it
generally works is is you do it a little
like my lateness thing you know it
didn't happen like instantly it's just
you say I don't want to have that habit
anymore we all have bad habits and if
you tell yourself the truth and don't
give yourself excuses reasons you will
change if you want to it's just getting
out of bed you know I mean you think he
could get out of bed if he wants to no
matter what his history I used to have a
friend he used to train people on giving
up smoking and he could get a big
auditorium like this and he'd say and
had no smoking signs around he go how
many of you are smokers and they'd all
raised their hands
and he says why I don't see anyone with
a cigarette in their mouth okay the
point was that was their perception of
themselves but they weren't smokers at
that moment and that's the whole thing
with you you have a perception of
yourself with the bad habit you can
change it if you do it a step at a time
and forgive yourself you're not going to
change it immediately so you're going to
screw up I would use a different word
but we're on TV you screw up okay but
doesn't matter it's okay now next time
you'll do it and you will do it if you
want to do it I guarantee you that if
you want to do it if he really wants to
get out of bed if she really wants to
figure out how to collect almighty you
can do it it's not necessarily the first
time when you can do it so yeah we all
have bad habits I have you have them so
burning human yes we're done this was so
wonderful please join me in thanking